こう部屋さ
人がたくさん来るわけだが
私は思ったんですよイス持ってほしくないんです
ず何度がいっしょがあるんだけどもスプーンかさばらないんですか
こういうのとかさこういういってさ横幅が広いから
これもかっこいいのさそんなのはせっ
そうなああああ
こういう石田智子の横尾これがあってここで集団解決しようとするかかさなんですよね
このいつもそうここあるんですよ便利なんですけど
集団で使うとき場所を取りすぎてて若干不便を感じることありませんか
みんなに聞いても言えるは彼らはありませんかたしてたまにみんなで奥義するときた
これが邪魔でさあ当たってる人とかいるわけで行くよくねえと思うよつまり5個2灯
よりた分たくさんの人でなるべくスペースを取らずつあることが我々の神の椅子の目的
なのかなと思いますね私パイプいす1クラス分買いました
まず1クラス分んだろうか3002結果くださいね
いらー皆や1回ペースにはね私は不思議な魅力があると思うんですよ値段で式卒業式
お坊さんは床に座りますか立っ
パルプ基本何かのそういう行事って結構回プレイする人はってですが多いからなぜか
買い食い性が魅力的だからなんですよはい家から一番一変ところあるんで結局イチロー
のパイプ椅子に素晴らしいですよええええ
パティペイジそりゃあそういうことねあの天下の返済イチローもうタイプぜひあの壁
ダメられる肇社長も帯別に座るもう台北に座るしかないというわけで京子姉のパイプ
st 街の磯で提供して今から我々3人で力を合わせてみんなが車にこの部屋アイ
ピースいっぱいにしようと思いますそしてパイ pg なきゃいけなかったこのいいを
見て見ぬふりまるで興味がなかっえこれ一瞬のリフォームオーダーだ
のかモテないかこの部屋から今度から32日中になるのかでいう巨大でキャパシティを
好き better 対する返事だってくるってゆけでまずはハイピース以外の邪魔年
筆を全て解除します
ene
あーを受けれ
音月いいのにそっからと付いた俺が5椅子を運びます
どっこいしょお届けはいこちらアイピースです
応用ガール2んだとりあえずなんですけどもこれだけで4つ入っていうとちょっとお得
なやつですやっぱネーミングチェアーとか色んな人座ってきたんですけどハイペースが
一番いい僕も含めて家で働いてる全員のことを考えアイピースで見尽くしてみんなの
健康を保ちたいっ
うわぁせばコンパクトやなぁ
メインのすぐのカレンってはいとても良いペースだと思いますよ
ん
加盟していますうん
どんどん増えていきますの
i am
[音楽]
hi-fi ピース32個全部出しましたやばいん
ヤバイぞ
ブーブーきれいに並べて言ってうううーードゥ
は高校の入学です1冊業種の保護者の方たちが座るパイプ椅子を片付けてた係だったの
で思い出します
まあやんなかったんだけどねぇ
ます
詰まって多すぎるかもしれない
ああ
[音楽]
山ソースまで意見こそ創造の何倍も大変なことになってしまいました歩くスペースが
ありません俺もうちょっといけると思うんだよなぁ
つまら汚いですもうちょっと綺麗にしましょう
ん
んの
はーはっはっは
はいというわけで今なら僕に言いに来ても30人まで入れるよ
なんかすごい自分でシリーズを作って気分ですよこれ kk
a
すごいすごいすごいすごいずっとそこのけなぜか超えるっ子へ着席ここないは30人
まで人が来ても大丈夫です
いやすごいどうぞ
はっはああ
もだかこれですわ良材だぞねってもいいですねってもいいぞあそこにほら先生の碩学
元祖こと気をつけませんを先生が座る席ですここで出すといい何よね
2-1
ん
[音楽]
僕笹
ani
川
高く
ブーブー
[音楽]
て終わる al
風をカーン
なにこれたっ歯が折れます
凍っん
[音楽]
me
kinoo
car
多額聞こえる
yeah
goo シーラーよ
みんなー
みー
んな
ああああああ
命を休んだ
押野曜日
を食べるー
のようにいい
いえいえい
愛を超えが
だぞなった
各寄港を得るえええ
いいいいいいいいよ
いいんなぁ
yeah
みんな
[音楽]